hey David what would happen if you
abolished the minimum wage okay so this
there's been a lot of talk about a 15
minimum wage lately and we learned last
week that Chipotle in order to account
for paying 15 bucks an hour is Raising
prices four percent which is a really
really modest increase it's like 26
Cents on your average chicken burrito uh
even though everybody will earn 15 an
hour and there are some sort of
libertarian right-wing types who say
listen the the minimum wage is an
artificial price floor
and it um is simply a bad it's a price
control it's bad for the economy it
keeps people out of the workforce if you
eliminated the minimum wage sure wages
might come down a little bit but way
more people would end up becoming
employed and that would be good for the
economy because then they would pay
taxes and okay first of all
if you saw a decrease to the minimum
wage that's significant and it led to
more employment a lot of those people
because the wage would be so low
would would not or would barely pay any
federal taxes so in in reality the tax
thing may even be be wrong number one
number two we have a counter example to
this okay the value of the minimum wage
remember if you have a seven dollar
minimum wage and you have inflation the
value of that minimum wage actually goes
down if you're the employer
and there is inflation meaning your
product or service sells for more but
you pay the same nominal minimum wage
you are actually seeing a decrease to
the minimum wage in real terms we had a
situation in the 1980s where the minimum
wage the the actual value of the minimum
wage went down about a third because of
inflation and we actually saw teen
employment drop site slightly this is
the big claim from the right all of
these teenagers and entry-level workers
and what we call less skilled workers
they would have way more employment if
the minimum wage were to go down well
the minimum wage did go down in real
terms during the 1980s and significantly
so just under a third uh 32 percent I
believe the number is and you did not
see Teen employment explode because it
all of a sudden became uh really cheap
to hire people it got cheaper for
businesses to hire because of that
stagnant minimum wage and they didn't
and as I've said so many times when
before when it comes to Taxation and
hiring and the minimum wage if a
business is understaffed relative to the
demand for their product or service then
it would make sense to go and add a new
worker and if you can get that worker
for Less well okay even better for the
business I guess but it's not profitable
to just add workers because it's cheaper
to add them it doesn't make sense think
about it you know with the David packman
show
if we actually have a an unmet need
either because we have so much demand
for advertising that I need more sales
people or we have so much demand for
memberships that I need to bring on a
full-time web developer to keep up with
the website traffic or whatever the case
may be just because it becomes cheaper
to hire someone doesn't mean I'm
actually going to go and hire someone
unless I'm servicing uh demand now what
would actually increase demand and this
is where the right just kind of seems to
not not get it or pretend not to get it
what would increase demand for
memberships
it would be people having more money
and one way to put more money in the
pockets of people who might only
borderline be able to afford a
membership right now would be a minimum
wage increase now I think there are some
Fair assessments about the minimum wage
that come from the right one is most
people don't make minimum wage
and because wages tend to be sticky
wages don't tend to come down if you got
rid of the minimum wage it's unlikely
that most people's wages would come down
if you're in a job where you make the
equivalent of 25 bucks an hour it might
be 25 bucks an hour or it might just be
a fifty thousand dollar a year salary
right if the minimum wage went down or
even was eliminated it's not hugely
likely at least right away that you
would end up earning less money but
there is a particularly vulnerable class
of workers particularly when we're
talking about immigrants talking about
people in disadvantaged uh neighborhoods
that already often have the sort of
structural disadvantages of terrible
public transit and so on and so forth
those are the first folks who are going
to be taken advantage of and there's
going to be this downward pressure and
the the whole point of the minimum wage
is not to ensure everybody makes 50
Grand a year that would require 25 five
dollar minimum wage at every job in many
states that are low cost of living it
that's not it's just not an equilibrium
wage and I know there's many people who
say the minimum wage should be 25 bucks
an hour you know in rural Alabama a 25
an hour minimum wage is out of
equilibrium with business profitability
and cost of living in some big cities
that probably is the right minimum wage
but the point here is you are going to
see uh the most disadvantaged and those
with the least Market power to advocate
for themselves taken advantage of now
the right will then come back in and say
well they can then organize and they can
all agree we're not going to work for
less than x and they can push prices up
and demand to be paid more that's what
unions do now and those same right
Wingers are against unions and they're
against collective bargaining and on and
on and on so you really have to step
back from the talking points on this if
you eliminate the minimum wage is it
likely that a lot of people would start
working for 50 cents an hour no that's
not likely but the federal minimum wage
is already pathetic uh and uh what you
the the other thing by the way that's
important to remember is reducing the
minimum wage will shift the burden of
paying people away from businesses and
towards the government if you reduce the
minimum wage you're also basically
setting up a bigger government handout
and subsidy because
the benefits and Welfare programs that
individuals will start to qualify for if
you scrap the minimum wage and you see
somewhat of a reduction you know 725
maybe some people start working for six
or five dollars an hour or 450 or
whatever
um the the fact that more people will
work which doesn't appear to be true but
even if it were true more people will
work if you reduce the minimum wage
um they whatever they pay in to the
government you will lose because they
will qualify for
um a government welfare programs that
cost the government money that come out
of taxes anyway so the point of the
minimum wage is let's agree and
establish some minimum that makes sense
based on cost of living based on
equilibrium wages based on what we
consider to to be
um a a reasonable standard to set we're
not talking about a fifty dollar an hour
a hundred dollar an hour minimum wage
and it should be in balance with the
broader economy and prevent the most
vulnerable from being taken advantage of
that's really the point and the
hypotheses about well if more money is
good pay people 100 bucks or if you get
rid of the minimum wage people will be
working for 10 cents an hour you're
focusing on these the extremes and
you're really sort of missing the big
picture
one of our sponsors today is Helix sleep
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about Helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you I took the Sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what I needed I often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and I've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all Helix mattresses come
with a 10 year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
I think you will all of my viewers will
get up to 200 off your order and you'll
get two super premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video